good morning Millennials oh my god we're
three minutes late or okay I know
honestly ma'am but we have upgraded to
the official we are sponsored by the
official snitch cam cut it wave to
everyone Margo you look hilarious in
those headphones you're ready for
takeoff I am are we ready for blast-off
are we ready for the toast I think so do
you have all your facts yes all systems
are go are you doing a research all
systems are go all systems are go thank
God oh my god Margo I'm watching you
look so I think you and you're gonna
like you look tan that ring light is
very flattering it is
anyways hello everyone it's a long since
we last saw you we had such a crazy week
last week furball
I'm sorry that was so disgusting that's
been happening to me lately it just must
be a side effect of being very healthy I
don't know yeah you're coughing up fur
yeah
like Co no I still keep sleeping with
you so I'm like inhaling his it's yeah
it's been so long since we've been back
okay let's recap what happened because I
wasn't your Thursday Friday me and Marga
are out in West Palm Beach which by the
way it's just so beautiful like me and
Margo we seen it a Hilton which is like
you know a very standard hotel I
literally felt like I was at the Waldorf
it was so nice the whole town is just
like wrapped in luxury it's obviously a
very expensive place to live but I
really enjoyed spending 24 hours there
me Margo also went out which was like so
weird cuz usually when we do shows we're
like in bed right after because I'm so
tired but like I don't want to celebrate
last week was particularly treacherous
because I had four shows in Philly and
then one in Palm Beach I just want to
celebrate the fact that like this week
was completed and it was a success for
the most part except today success is
for a couple things it felt like it's
fine but you can't like no I can't even
think about so much success at least a
couple things in Philly which I bet you
are nothing no you know yeah so so we
went out and it was lit but you know
what's so weird we definitely take
advantage for here like me and Margo
went out we probably got to the place B
record suppose to be it like 11:40 and
it was like empty and like we stayed for
a while and like we were ready to keep
going at like one o'clock like things
just closed it's like everything closed
it's like you have to go home where's
like in New York if you want to keep
part
then you can find a place that's open
however we went out Saturday night and
it was a goal bus to be not true there's
and I feel strong I'm strong about the
fact that New York nightlife you guys is
just it's not pop in it's very sad
landscape for New York nightlife
landscape the landscape is very sad like
we had the greatest night ever on
Saturday night we won't get to it in a
second but after the greatness we wanted
to continue the greatness and like we're
thinking of places to go that are just
like our vibe where we can bring it down
we're just thinking places to go that
are great great that are our vibe where
we could break it down without taking
like an elbow to the eye and there's no
there's nothing in this town and the one
place that we liked that we went to
Jackie just revealed that she saw a
cockroach well as we're walking in like
to my left I saw something scoot by my
legs I shined my flashlight on it's a
guy who works there was like what's
wrong I was like that's a cockroach she
was like oh and I didn't tell my sisters
cuz I didn't want to ruin their good
time that is so nice because like it
wouldn't even occur to me not to tell
you guys would be like holy [ __ ] there's
a road the reason why it occurred to me
not to tell you is because earlier in
the night at another place in town I saw
a different cockroach and I told you we
were waiting in the shree I said oh my
god there's a cockroach and I freaked
you out so much and then was like why
would you tell her so I learned my
lesson saw another cockroach didn't tell
you and I just want to say just like a
part of living in New York no but like
it shouldn't be you shouldn't see two in
one night in two completely different
parts of town I totally like that is the
cockroach jackpot and we were talking on
Friday night about how the city is not
what it used to be and especially after
this uber ban that Ben and I got into on
Thursday and then kind by the way I
watched I watched every time I'm not
here I like check-in while I'm on the
plane because it's usually streaming
when I'm on the plane and like the Wi-Fi
is not good enough but I just watch to
make sure like no one's doing a better
job than me but both Ben and had their
were doing like almost as good a job as
me and like I was getting kind of
nervous
but I watched Ben's episode in full just
because the Wi-Fi on this Delta flight
was amazing like I live I could have
live streamed my child birds like it was
so premium and so high quality like I
could see up in your nose that's so
amazing I love to hear it would great
job and the toast is amazing like I
don't see I don't like feel the value of
the toast that other people feel when
they watch it cuz like when you are at
work like an hour and 10 minutes takes
forever but when you're watching
something like you really enjoy like the
time really flies by on this plane it
was only like a two-hour plane ride and
between like landing and initial descent
and like taking off
chose to got my whole plane right and I
had so many things to do when I just
like I'm gonna watch episode and then
I'll do the episode was over and the
plane ride was over and I was just like
what I was almost like sad to get off
the plane was it crazy
you were just stepped onto a plane Waja
Tosun transport it to a different land
shut up I never said that no II just
really like I feel the value of the
chose I was a toaster for a minute like
I'm obviously a toaster but no no wait a
head toaster i under you understood like
the role that the toes plays in people's
daily life and then work that we do yeah
so important and when people come up to
us and they're like literally the toast
saves lives and like I know but like it
saves lives and I'm just of the mindset
now where I'm like I'm back like I feel
like this these past maybe two weeks I
feel back do you not I mean know there
was a moment when we were on top of the
world memory were in the Super Bowl and
we looked at each other and we were just
like we're living the dream like we were
just like we were so grateful for like
everything that was happening and like
yes something's change and that no
longer happens but I feel like this week
I like got back to that feeling of like
being so grateful and like this is our
jobs like this is the greatest show
literally this is the greatest show we
light it up we won't come down and the
breath can't stop us now impossible
comes true it's taking over you the
toast is the greatest show it really
isn't like I got back to that place of
just being like so happy and so grateful
and I was like I don't know what it was
I was just like the toast is the ready
show maybe it was experiencing the toast
as a toaster that made me feel the
gratefulness you know no I gratitude
like it there are times when doing this
show well I mean every morning waking up
and going to work is treacherous
but like the past few weeks the episodes
have been so strong so fulfilling that
we come here we sit down we feel like
ass and by the time we get up like I
have a newfound energy the toast is a
drug guys ever in your row say to bed
last night oh my god so good I know Ben
felt it too because when he sat down in
this chair he was like nervous he's like
let's go over everything and by the end
of it he was like wow he amazed he
called me he's like I think I should do
more stuff on camera that was so fun I'm
like Ben that was fun because like
literally the whole interview was about
you like you had to interview someone
else it's like way less interesting but
he was like he was hooked he was like I
I need me on camera more like what
should we do the toast is a drag the
toast is a Jew rug and everyone who
comes on feels it and I was literally
saying to Ben last night because I got
home when did we get home I wrote Friday
it was the first weekend home in forever
and like I was just I kept saying I'm
like I have an appointment to be at
peace with the world
I was so [ __ ] excited what did I do I
was up till 4:00 in the morning working
on the toast Murch site like I was
saying to Ben like I think I'm no more
colic man I never thought I would say
that because I hate working I hate the
concept of working here the concept of
moving but like I'm so passionate about
the choice and like I just want
everything we do to be a like a success
like we are churning it out for cam
toast like the content is gonna be a
premium like and the people have signed
up are so excited the camp toast a
Facebook group which is just four
members only it's like so late and so
excited and like I'm just so excited to
have like the fire beneath me but like
I'm a workaholic I've decided like I'm
one of those people like every time I'm
your child like fulfills you and every
time I'm home I'm on my computer just
like work on that but there's even so
much to work I'm but like I'm always
thinking of like what's next for us and
even when like I'm not doing working on
something specific like not reading
contracts for cam toast so that we're
all in a good place right and safe um
like just doing membership for other PS
like the toast just never sleeps nor
should it because like it's so fantastic
and you know what it is it's like and I
know this sounds so lame like we're
entrepreneurs know we are now that I'm
watching shark tank it's like fulfilling
me in a whole other way we are
entrepreneurs and I think that before
like we weren't so like every time the
toast benefits like our brand benefits
and like we benefit where I was like
back with the old show it was like it
was about someone else so it's about
like a medium now you're working you're
putting into the more and you don't get
you don't get to reap the rewards and
right you don't get to reap the fruits
of your labor and now all of our labor
we bear the fruits so it's so crazy how
like and I know that they say this
someone's something bad is happening to
you you can't think this way but like
everything happens for a reason this is
true we should be on the cover of
entrepreneur Forbes whatever call us
call us you know I'm just like I have a
new reinvigorated sense of life for
myself in my brand I totally gained I
have to I have to say I think some of
that for you and for me comes from
Lauren Alaina and Luke owns because
Saturday night was the night of our
lives it was new it was a recharge I
needed it was a recharging emotionally
not physically I don't ever go to
another concert just being like okay
trailer sent in the stands so it was
actually night in MSG and it's so
awesome because we go to country
concerts all the time around New York
and they never ever ever been at Madison
Square Garden they're very rarely even
in the city we use it to drive like an
hour and a half
two hours have place in New Jersey
either or JoJo's beach there's never a
country concert in New York because
country isn't like a big market I mean
New York is in a big country for Mart
New York City is in a big country music
market however apparently 94.7 is the
number-one country music station in the
country and you know it's shout-out to
our upstate New Yorkers cuz you know New
York City is not holding it down -
chatter - Katie Neil who is the host of
94 7 and when we were in the car on the
way to the Hamptons she was on it so
weird cuz like we know her because we
always see her she's the one of the
hosts like the radio host we always seen
her at these concert to me become good
friends and she's really nice and we
heard her on the radio and I text her
I'm like let me hear you on the radio
and she said on the radio Claudia and we
were dying it so it's the small
victories it really is but that's so
crazy cool anyway so 94.7 that congrats
on being number one right we were so
surprised someone was like you know that
the country radios biggest station is
the New York station and we were like
why were the only when I got a new red
zone they can you put on 94.7 they're
like what we're like Nash FM 94 7 Nash
Nights live and so the three of us
snitch and us are holding it down in New
York City for country music anyways
apparently New York City loves Jason
Aldean because it was like all about
show literally born Lena Lou combs were
the two openers and by the end of Lou
combs the stadium was completely full
which is something that you never see
even for like Drake you know you know if
you've been to a concert at Madison
Square Garden you know that the opener
can be like sad it's like it's just
sometimes like a little awkward because
you know this is the person's big break
and like there's so many empty seats and
like nobody really knows your song and
then by the end of it like it's kind of
fun like you have that one song that
everyone knows it can be like it can be
awkward but from the second one got on
stage like the place was hot was Ben
jump in and so were we so Lauren Alaina
set and we so we went the three of us
and Ben and Zach even though like I
didn't need them there like I needed I
needed my sister's there - no - I agree
I didn't need them there but I knew that
they would love Luke owns and like they
think we're annoying with the country
stuff I got I know every time I'm
putting on country Ben thinks I'm
annoying but I knew once he saw Luke
lumps in person like Luke Holmes songs
are amazing 100% but it's more his
energy and like his vibe and the fact
that he doesn't look like every like
pretty boy country star stage president
like he just walks around a stage with
solo cup just like riffing and singing
his song differently every time because
he can't because he's so like musically
inclined yes and so I knew that they
would love Luke Combs but Lorna Lina
came on first and they were like shook
back they couldn't believe how good her
voice was they could not believe and
they loved her songs they were just
sitting down we were standing up singing
snapchatting whatever they were so now
I'm like enjoying the show anyways she
was amazing
then Lew combs comes on and we're just
like living per usual then we run into
his girlfriend oh yes Nicole who is
definitely Djoser at heart and she was
just like I don't know what to expect
she was just like so cute and skinny
like I literally wanted to eat her for
breakfast yes she was fat except a it up
in a pan with like a little barbecue
sauce so she came and then like once we
were at her we were like in so we just
started we just like we're walking
around like no one was thinking twice
about us you know what I'm saying now
I'm saying so we Lauren was on we
literally exuded all my energy when
Lauren was on and then Lauren went
backstage I don't want to bother her
because like this was a big moment for
her and we started to enjoy Luke and
then when Luke was on Nicole wanted a
fun place to watch so she came and watch
with us and then once she started
watching with us we were like let's go
down to like the cool section so Nicole
took us down and then Lauren came out so
it's just like everything was happening
for us and we there was like this little
section side of side of stage we're like
just cool people hung out and I've
literally never had a better time in my
whole life that's where we live - food
comas like just from Sidis age with the
crew just one of them one of the one of
the stars
then we went backstage we know I'm not
done with the Luke concert right first
of all we speculated a lot about Luke
combs is like we're like what is it
about Luke Holmes that we find so
enticing because you know he's not
traditionally like conventionally hot
but like his spirit is so good looking
and I'm like attracted to his citrus at
his spirit spirit like he's so
good-looking and like I don't know why
and then we figured it out it's because
he definitely emulates some sort of BDE
big-dick energy and I got to experience
the bde like from 50 feet away and it
was very strong so I just wanted to
confirm with you that we were right the
toasters guessed it the bde is real and
like I don't know I became obsessed with
him I know you did and then we got to
meet him which was like even better and
you know what it is country is so in
tune with what's necessary and they
respect the hell out of the chose do you
really do so everyone vaccine if we were
backstage at like a Demi Lovato concert
he's like what are you doing here we
wouldn't be able to get back seat
everyone is just like so chillin it's
like because they they know they're
doing good were like they're not so
preoccupied with other people I feel
like usually in the biz like everyone's
like looking at each other who's this
person yeah get them out of here like
the talent the talent but like the
talent was just like hanging with
everyone everyone like knew who the
toast was they knew how big of a deal
everyone's like girlfriend knew who the
toast was or like sister so even if they
weren't toasters themselves they were
toasters by association it was just like
a group of people who were like mutually
had respect for one another and the best
part about Luke Holmes that is an
interesting factoid that I hope it's not
a big deal that I'm saying but he
travels with this you know like all
music they have like the sound box
they're like those big black trunks that
like carry like equipment here's one and
when you open it up it's a bar like the
sides open and it's like covered in
cowhide it's like so rich and it has
like a red cup dispenser it's like so
cute and like no one was charging me no
one was looking at me when I was like
filling up a hundred times like it was
so funny he just opens it and people
like gather around it and we were we
were gathering we gather round yeah Luke
omen.oh came out and took a picture with
us and he was so sweet
even though he was like who are these
girls like why are they so short why are
they like some we were just like so high
energy because we were like energizer
bunnies like we could in stop and he was
just like so nice and took a picture
with us I got a solo shot but I don't
like us cute so I put up the group
picture what upper it sign and then we
walked backwards it's not about how we
look it's about how we felt totally and
then we went back to Lauren's dressing
or me just like made her sing for us a
hundred times cuz like her voice is so
good and my favorite thing is during her
set she was like so I don't know if you
guys know this but I am I started my
career on American Idol thank you to
everyone who voted for me like it was so
funny and her like that's why Benton's
act couldn't get over her like her voice
is so crazy it's so great and her songs
are so good and her voice is so good but
then like when she just like goes off
riffs it's beautiful so Ben had the
pleasure she's having it's like her
moment now she's like she's ten so we
I've been working for so long for so
hard and like my first three songs were
just like flops and I really thought
like I wasn't it wasn't gonna happen for
me and like that night was a big night
her and like just like be there like
next to her but it was her big day it's
a mystery like a sold-out audience like
I can't even imagine the feeling no me
neither
but I got to do a 12-hour theater I got
close to imagining the feeling because
we were like in her dressing room which
is like you know like so many people
have like done drugs in that dressing
room like it's an iconic dressing
for sure it's a big deal that dress from
the bathroom was so fancy and ice and it
had like a glam room and we were
definitely overstay our welcome but we
didn't care and we were having the best
time I mean like all these plans to go
out but then her flight to Orlando got
canceled it's like she had to rearrange
and like we had to go to karaoke
we had to scram yeah it was our time you
know yeah just like that's the stadium
that scene was done this arena was empty
we didn't know we had like lost time
just like singing with Lauren's right
and we stood we went we went to the
concert for Jason Aldean for maybe 5
minutes which is not me I'm not gonna
stay for him at all so it's good but I
just wanna say like props to Jason
Aldean we didn't realize like the
magnitude no idea case you like I said I
really didn't realize no and I'm like
he's like so stocky stocky stocky he
like doesn't have a neck you know no
he's compact yeah very small but he just
is a huge huge star I had no idea for
bringing country music into New York
City at MSG for the like he's bigger
than lose Brian yeah when I get Ryan
once open for Jason Aldean that's so
cheesy
they say he's bigger than the Blake
Shelton too but they both of them have
those shows that like give them how it
is Jason Aldean hands know I'm saying
Blake and Luke both have the voice and
American Idol which really puts them on
like a mainstream map and then Jason
like just has music I feel like Jason's
going more of like the Garth Brooks
route you know what I mean
sort of but then there's also the exact
brown man who sold out Citi field's two
nights in your own City field it's like
MetLife it's math you know what's a
crown is Scooter Braun right yeah that's
what it is like if they're but look at
the power of the Brawn we need the power
of the Brawn oh my god how did we get
Scooter Braun to represent the toast is
anyone you're related to him for sure
I'm sure like his cousin's watching you
I'm telling you the power of the toast
like every time you want something just
put it out in the universe like I some
girl message me and she was like I'm
gonna do it amazing seats at Lauren
aleena like I do like I do seats for
Madison's her garden she's like I can't
really explain my job but like I get
good tickets like do you want Knicks
tickets courtside I'm like yeah yes
please put it out into the universe and
ye shall receive okay is that all of our
catching up to do oh my god I got shamed
on Instagram by my teeth-whitening
company I saw they were like come see us
cuz you were complaining at your
criteria so yellow and I actually made
an appointment today I'm going and it's
actually I didn't think you could like
that you didn't have to go to the
dentist to get your teeth whitened
I've never gotten my teeth whitened you
know I use Crest Whitestrips and like
the mio don't smile
they look really good okay they crashed
my tips don't work for everyone and
people say they were in the enamel on
your teeth but then the dentist set and
I asked her and I do have sensitive
teeth and I have to use Sensodyne but
the dentist said like if they work for
you and they don't hurt they're great
like congratulations that they work for
you so how can you do it it depends on
like I'm sure like the week before my
wedding I'll do it like twice a week
sometimes I'd do it like once a month I
should start once a week I think is the
better before you read I usually at this
place it's called LaVon first of all
just love the name because LaVon means
white in Hebrew they have two locations
in the city I think whitening my teeth
would hurt my teeth like that's too
strong for me I have very sensible Ben
is very sensitive teeth and he's still
did it
I'll talk to the doctor today and not
that I'm not gonna add [ __ ] or anything
and I don't read any benefits from this
but because they know that like the
number one toaster in the world goes to
their teeth whitening place they gave me
a code so if you're the City West
Village Upper East Side and you want to
get your teeth whitened
gwm jeg ones 20% off like that's helpful
and I don't think it's that expensive
and if you do it like once a year I
think it's like eighty dollars and then
with my code like what's 20% of evening
what 70 dollars it's really good and I
don't read any benefits I just I'm here
to help the toasters get white teeth I
am something more like code because you
should I haven't gone to the dentist
since I lost my health insurance really
[ __ ] sad you guys I forgot you so
bill DeJohn
I know so I'd be careful I know who I'm
walking on eggshells so actually I
actually need your code you think he can
give me a teeth cleaning yes okay I'll
go I'll go there by the way and the
doctor is nobody's serving up dental
insurance
he's so hot well that's the thing like
that's why I love City MD because
literally up until two months ago when I
got fired I didn't have health insurance
because I had with NYU and then I like
never got and then I never had a real
job but then I was like about to get it
on our show and then I got fired so um
now I'm on beds health insurance but
like this is the first time I've really
had health insurance like in four or
five years which is just so crazy you
feel like so secure like he was dreaming
or like hit me bro no I thought I was
like gonna go hit up a million doctors
like the good ones don't even take
insurance I got my chair my chin no and
you're in soon I'll be there so it's
like oh what when I get like a
colonoscopy I'm good you know even the
doctor said I do go to they don't even
take insurance what is it nobody takes
insurance except my dentist did and
they're like you have a copay I'm like
what you know and then it's like pay
with a credit card like I'm only been
like you're in
surance sends you a credit card to use
and it's like if you touch that thing
you're gonna get hip out by debt
collectors for the next 100 except those
cards the only place they really work on
drugs at your uggs are like a million
dollars like you have insurance I pull
out this like a rinky-dink award you're
the are their insurance card yeah that
works for a lot of stuff but they also
send you a credit card that you're
supposed to use at the doctor but you
guys do not touch it I'm telling you it
is Debt Collection curse I've never
tried to know that you could get like
health care out like businesses do you
don't I mean like you did say oh you up
teeth singing you're the dentist
no go to Livan they're so clean and so
they've TV you could watch like when I'm
sick I'm I going to go to the doctor
$300 no City MD and it's like I got my
wisdom teeth out when I had insurance
and like I was told insurance would
cover some of it and then it didn't so
and I always tell you like after the
procedure you know yeah they're like
you'll hear back in two to three weeks
in the mail ya know it's just like I'm
living for like these new businesses
that are like that are just changing the
way Urgent Care see that Shark Tank
episode with that girl who started a
company that was like changing the way
DNA that they were doing testing yep and
they seal because you wonder why she
didn't need the money
she like had enough money and she had a
ton of it I really change the whole
health care system but that guy I'm the
same episode when an app called hater
got a deal no the the politics of shark
tank I can't even go into because we're
ready we said almost 25 minutes and we
need to start doing the stories but
right this is because snitch asks for a
short episode today why did you ask for
a short episode snitch what are you so
busy from doing know being your sister
oh that's look she's a high by the
sister yeah it's she's an a sister I'm a
master okay that's a great title for you
well sing Lady tired yesterday I
literally is a day that fell off of my
calendar because I did not accomplish or
get up or do one thing I slept the whole
day from like more I didn't expect I
never woke up isn't that so crazy it
must be nice have you ever had a date
like booted out of my house oh I heard
we know I'm sorry I have a totally sorry
because if there are any toasters who
are real estate agents like I need you
to feel my pain me a better moving
pending approval from our board but the
apartment were in now our lease is up
relatively soon so they've been trying
to get someone to rent it and they are
you making appointments and she asked me
like a week ago she's like the realtor
was like can we have an open house on
Sunday
and I said sure which is just annoying
for me except to wake up early like
clean the house get out for two hours
and it's like a Sunday so after the Lord
Elena concert I was dead I set an alarm
for 11:30 and I literally felt like I
was waking up at 6:00 a.m. you know
ready to go to war I cleaned my entire
house I took away all of our pictures
like I just didn't know if like someone
was coming in like that I want them
knowing it was my house like taking a
video of it's like I scrubbed every
trace of me and dad made it look like
we're does a normal folk and I left and
I keep a camera for Theo but when
there's an own open house I keep a
camera just like if someone something
goes missing you know I like to know
look at the camera 12:40 no one's there
call the doorman I said hey is the
broker showing up yet he goes now 40
minutes later my god that's weird thirty
minutes go by it's now 115 call the
broker I'm gonna call the building I'm
like hey burger there yet he's like no
but there were a bunch of people waiting
downstairs for the open house and they
just left she could she called here and
said it was canceled I'm like what some
I'm emailing the broker and I'm just
like I know you don't know this about me
but like I traveled most weekends and
like this was the first weekend that I
was home and like I made a special
accommodation it's like wake up early
clean house be out so that you could
have a good open house and like find a
tenant and like for you aid not to tell
me that it was cancelled but even in
hours notice is so rude and considerate
she answered me till 3:30 the thing was
supposed to be over at 2:00 o'clock 3:30
she goes oh it's been canceled I'm like
and you're telling it 3:30 that's what
the 12 o'clock open house is cancelled
I'm like I know thing you don't know me
or care about me but like just like a
little heads-up would have been so
considerate and save me so much time and
energy and she's like oh we updated it
online you should have seen it I'm like
yes I'm following your open house online
I'm not even a tenant and she said we
got an application I'm oh great so you
won't need it next weekend for the open
house that we had scheduled never
answered me I swear in my life if home
girl tries to come to my house on a
Sunday I'm taking an armed guard outside
my door and no one is being let in I
just couldn't believe like how she
didn't care like I was so it was so
inconsiderate like I was so displaced
like she couldn't have give less of a
[ __ ] about me being displaced no I
totally the end the most fucked-up part
truly is that yesterday was Theo's
one-year anniversary of being coming ass
offer and we don't even get to celebrate
appropriately because he was locked out
of his house like a political refugee
anyways Theo congratulations on one year
in the big city you're doing so well my
time
yesterday and for the next week it's
probably gonna be the most premium
content because but then it's only a
week because the gladsome off to camp
but this week a year ago we got the O
and like he was so tiny and like I just
think back and he really hated being
with us like he was so afraid all the
time like he was so uninterested in like
being a part of our family I mean the
big city it's overwhelming that week was
so hard I remember sitting on the couch
after the week I'm like hysterically
crying because I was like I love feel so
much but like this is so hard no not
even that it was so hard cuz we were at
the breath and like I would bring him in
the in the little carry case but he
wasn't really allowed and just like it
was so difficult like with them and I
never knew what he wanted like it was so
scary and so sad I remember being like
so afraid and now I'm like I couldn't
imagine my life without you we love you
Co if you're watching and sneech s and
mom's snitches love you okay now without
further ado drumroll please thirty
minutes later and like I would literally
thirty minutes later sorry case but it
is time out and just like we get it
that's five stories that you need to
know so for your makeup is your morning
toast I could yes okay first story is
really sad this is news that came out on
Friday afternoon Bethenny Frankel well
Dennis Shields was found dead in his
apartment
Bethenny Frankel said that Dennis
Shields wasn't right but in days before
his death so I was on the plane when
this happened and Olivia put it in the
chat and everyone was freaking out and
the [ __ ] picture wasn't downloading
and I'm like what does everyone freaking
out about and I was like I'm imagining
what it could be and literally this was
the last thing I ever thought it could
be and for some reason I was like I
don't know him like I was so sad and
like I couldn't get over it like I
started talking to the flight attendant
about it because Margo was like not
saying in for Scott and I got upgraded
sorry and I just I needed someone to
talk to about I was like so upset like
bereft do you know like it's so
upsetting everything about the story's
upsetting and I feel like just as people
who love Bethany like you could tell
there's like so much love there even if
they're together or not right now and
we'll read all the facts but it's just a
terrible terrible two ways about it cuz
like I want to like gossip about it but
like at the end of the day like Dennis
isn't famous like he chose to date
someone who was in the line like like he
isn't famous and like he has kids and he
like barely chose to be on this show on
right so like I think there was one
scene where we met him and then like one
phone call yeah why do I feel like I
know you know I know it's cuz we feel
like you and I I know we feel the same
way like about Bethany like just like
wanting to be there for her and I'm
just like I'm so sad I'm so sad two days
before her on-and-off-again boyfriend
Dennis Shields died of an apparent
overdose Bethenny Frankel noted with
great regret on the Real Housewives of
New York that he just wasn't mr. right
and now shields his friends are
wondering if the admission set off a
deadly tailspin
oh no quote she basically said I love
him but I can never marry him one friend
said of Wednesday's episode in which
wrinkled old Co housewife during the
medley she could never live with shields
shields 51 was found dead at 9:00 a.m.
Friday and his Trump tower apartment so
are is paid chicks trying to say that
because of what aired on Real Housewives
last week that he had there insinuating
then that's like so mean and definitely
not true he definitely doesn't even
watch the show and she probably said she
couldn't live with him or marry him
because once she's been living alone for
a while and like if you're not gonna
marry someone which I don't think they
would ever have gotten married anyway
because they're both so successful on
their own and they're like older they've
been married there's no there's no no to
get married like kids have kids if
they're not gonna have kids together
then it would just like make things
complicated with their finances like
literally oh there's no need for
marriage richer I don't know I don't
know either but that's that's why I feel
like Kylie and Travis will never get
married either
that's like Kylie will never marry
anyone cuz shows in California
everything's community property and if
she's smart she'll never get mad right
she just has too much money so that's
how I felt about these two so honestly
page six but can I just say how
misleading my days is like because they
kept saying found dead at Trump Tower
and like when you hear Trump Tower you
just think like ooh
everything is always happening at Trump
Tower like he just lived there like yeah
like I was like what he wasn't in a
hotel right like people you thought it
was behind was a hotel too and like
crazy things go down totally this was in
his home and it's like there look
obviously everyone's looking to the
ladies to like see what happened and a
lot of people were upset with Sonia for
saying something like they thought it
wasn't her place or that it was too soon
but what I thought she said was like
really sweet and she didn't over share
and like she really is proving to be
such a good friend to Bethenny and I was
watching her and watched up and zyv with
Michael Rapaport the day before - she
looked absolutely gorgeous stunning that
dress Sonja Morgan I'm gonna buy it
it's the most gorgeous dress she's I
don't know what happened to her but it's
like something clicked in her brain and
she's memories she went like that rehab
or something he's in that retreat she's
there again in Costa Rica yeah we should
go no I know she's like literally all
should they don't she doesn't need any
dairy she's just like eating vegetables
like being at one and like she sounds
crazy when she says it but the pictures
look so beautiful and it's working
because she's never been more lucid a
hundred percent and she's still able to
drink yeah
so like and when she got drunk like like
it was just it wasn't like like it was
just like Sonia being fun like I'm just
so and I thought her what she said was
very respectful and I wasn't mad at her
for speaking on it too soon there was
some controversy around a tweet Bethenny
I mean a tweet Carole post yeah because
in like 30 minutes after the news broke
about Stannis Dennis Carroll tweeted
something that to a normal person would
seem super insincere and then she
tweeted again she's like oh I just heard
about Dennis so she's saying that when
she tweeted that first thing she didn't
know about Dennis and what it said was
someone was like you should feel bad for
Bethenny she's been through a lot and
Carole was like I mean I buried a
husband and she friends been three weeks
and I'm not and I've seen some of the
worst atrocities in the world and
Baghdad and I'm fine you know and people
thought that was directed towards the
whole dentist thing but then she claimed
to have not known about it until thirty
minutes later so I'll give her the data
but then there was it more there was
more because Carole and Dorinda went out
that night with Caroline Stanbury from
ladies London and the comments on both
of their instagrams were Roth saying
that like they're just so insensitive
they couldn't have waited to post it and
I feel two ways about it cuz like yes
they do it was definitely insensitive
but like they made it very clear that
they're not friends with Bethenny so
like this is like I'm like I'm not
surprised by it at all right but I'm
just surprised that they would like buck
public perception so much and post it
like right I'm not surprised that they
went out they should have a good time
and they're they're really not friend
and they're not connected to the Sun
right so they're not gonna all stay home
because a co-worker's right boyfriend's
that's all they are at this pass away
but you would think they would care what
other people thought about what they
were doing
no it was it was wild um some of the
facts are that he'd asked his assistant
to give him narcan an emergency opioid
antidote but was was dead when first
responders arrived sources said when it
is for narcan
like I guess as I say before no like as
he was overdosing I'm not sure it will
take some six weeks before toxicology
results can confirm if shield suffered
an opioid overdose an investigative
source said so we haven't heard from
Bethany no tweets no nothing and like
I'm just so sad for her like all I'm
thinking about is her and it's like
they're just some people in this world
who can't catch a break
and that's what we were saying the other
week when we were recapping the episode
before the boat it's like they're just
some people in this world like the world
revolves around them and there are also
just people in this world who just can't
catch a [ __ ]
and every time you think she's like
finally getting to the promised land of
like being away from all the treacherous
nests of her ex-husband no no it's like
something something even worse like you
think it's as bad as it's gonna get and
then you can't even fathom how bad it it
can and I'm just like I can't help but
just think about how sad I am for her
she is just like she's not a bad person
but bad things keep happening to her
and the good things happen to bad people
no but also good things are happening to
her - but it's like yes the good things
that are happening to her it's just
material things right and that she just
can't in like the stuff that would
fulfill her soul she that Department she
can't she can't get her and that's why I
think she was so like upset about the
breakup with Carol is because like
remember when she her vagina was
bleeding and she got that big surgery
and she's in the car and she's like I
don't have any family like you know you
had a surgery be like Zach everyone
would be a Toby I'll be at your house at
Carly like right everyone from all walks
of are like there's just no entity
amount of people that care about you
like imagine just like having this like
terrible like medical emergency and like
not having a family member to call like
that is so sad yeah
and so like in the departments where
it's like what's it like when you die
like no one cares about what's in your
bank account and the words of Kourtney
Kardashian but Bethenny doesn't have
like aside from Bryn like like that core
the people around her are people who
work for her right and it's not for lack
of trying
like she just can't catch a break she
tried to reconnect with her stepdad when
she was in Miami and like she really
it's not for lack of trying for sure she
really invests so much in these
relationships like with Jill Jason Jason
with Carole so like every time there's a
breakup like it's all the more
depressing because she has no other
people to fall back on I think that's
why maybe that's what carol was saying
like it's not that deep but carol didn't
want to be the one person for Bethenny
because I'm sure it's a lot definitely
like to be though though a number one
like the sister the friend the brother
the boyfriend the husband so Carol
didn't wasn't interested I'm interested
I'd like to file an application to be
Bethany's number one friend I'll take
number two um anyways we're thinking of
Bethany Dennis's family this is a
horrible horrible story so it's just
it's so sad and maybe see with everyone
yeah that's really it another sad story
I guess this is just somber gay Joe
summer day on the toast if you're having
a bad day you know listen to the first
30 minutes but family members say Aretha
Franklin
gravely ill I saw so much trial the
Queen of Soul is asking for our prayers
legendary singer Aretha Franklin is a
serious medical condition and surrounded
by her family in a Detroit Hospital
according to reports quote my good
friend Aretha Franklin is gravely ill
tweeted vdi the WDIV anchor ever odd
cast me on Monday morning she's asking
for your prayers at this time added NBC
reporter Harry Hairston spoke with close
friend of Arisa of a wreath of Franklin
and family iconic singer not doing well
honestly Aretha Franklin is so iconic
and so like otherworldly that sometimes
I forget that she's still around does
that make sense yes it's like you know
people who have passed or like they get
this like ethereal vibe to them and
they're like they were so amazing even
if they weren't just because they're not
with us they it's like they move into
sainthood and won right and she's still
there and she's still her look like
she's a saint but still a lot yeah I
just I find that so interesting and
that's really sad it's really sad and I
love how like modern pop culture like
they integrate her everywhere she's
always at like random award show singing
I know I like getting awards she so
deserves it I just feel like she's
otherworldly but she's not because she's
like of another time you know yeah like
we are still our archer merchandise
should be to be alive at the same time
as she our generation is like talentless
hacks totally that like make tons of
money for like not really having talent
and like Aretha Franklin is from the
time where like if you wanted to you
successful you have to be the best yeah
I said your business out of your ass and
that's what she has otherwise you go
home now people really think like if you
can sing a note that you deserve a
record contract like that's why all
these people in like American Idol or
like the voice it's like some people
you're just born with a good voice for a
little controversial but you don't have
to work at it
and just because you are born with that
doesn't mean that you should be a singer
why don't you just like go work a job
and then come home and sing to your
family like you should like not everyone
who has a good voice should be a singer
thank you
I chose the path with less resistance
like I'm gonna be way that you use your
voice it's perfect
right like I have don't get me wrong I
know I have an amazing voice and like
when I was saying with Lauren Alaina
I've never felt worse about myself like
I have a good voice I'm not I don't
think if I had pursued singing I would
be anywhere successfully like maybe in a
few years if I'm really famous like I'm
trying to parlay this like Hailee
Steinfeld move from I could ask her
nominated actress into pop star I mean I
mean I mean
show host right but like I know I know
that I'm good I'm not great and I know
that like if I'd pursued this full-time
as a senior here like it wouldn't be a
thing the thing is you even are great
but you still shouldn't pursue this
full-time as a singing morally I was
singing the climb I was like I'm ready
to show her how good my voice is and
then like when we were singing together
I was like this is embarrassing wait
spoiler alert because we have some
amazing footage of Claudian been singing
with lauren that's gonna be up we did
that we filmed a behind-the-scenes
documentary feature on the future on the
saturday night and honestly when i
started filming and i just thought it's
gonna be us dancing in the concert going
home like i didn't realize that what we
were in for right I didn't realize the
premium content that would that would be
knocking on my door so that episode
would be up later today on the patreon
patron calm Sasha morning toast if you
are curious of hearing the best
rendition of the climb I've ever heard
and honestly I had to sit that one out
you guys because I wanted it to be good
no it was it was embarrassing no it was
like I felt embarrassed no it was she
was just like riffing and she was
getting better but you were still very
good yeah I wasn't bad no you didn't
embarrass yourself but I kind of agree
with you when people are like I mean I
was born to do this like no maybe you
were just born with a good voice but you
were born to like I don't know work in
radio look you know like even me some
Ramzi like he was born to like seeing at
Walmart's and make people happy he
happened to like get this whole career
out of it which is amazing but he could
have lived his whole life like working
on a farm and yeah Walmart singing wall
song that would have been enough I agree
with you not every person who was born
like with a good voice like needs to
either calling we're even a great voice
yeah and that's like that's where I get
frustrated with like the voice when it's
like these people who have families and
they're like you know I'm struggling
musician I have been able to put food on
the table for my family
that's a responsible know also like
having it a great voice is a cool party
trick
like that's it sometimes for you it's
like controversial I don't think so but
because having a good voice is something
you are born with it's not you just got
lucky I agree and I am a trainee I got
unlucky training that voice to like do
amazing things that is a skill but like
a skill that can be learned that can be
learned but you can't learn to have a
good voice like you're definitely just
born with it maybe it's maybe she's born
with it maybe it's mabeline maybe maybe
perhaps okay next story and more
positive yeah vibrant news to 11:11 make
a wish I wish
you know you're in a good place when
like the first media twist you know
there's that one thing no I always have
the same wish I usually I always have
the same wish to but now like I'm
wishing for more specific things because
like the overall things they're hard to
see if they came true so true I'm like I
specifically just want to find I want to
win the lottery you know my birthday is
always the same as like when I go to the
Kotel like when I'm praying right
honestly it's just like I want everyone
around me to be like top you can say to
someone come check please I just I'm I
always like I want my friends family my
friends family and like friends of
friends and family family to be just
like happy healthy wealthy yeah but
you'll never know is your wish came true
I know and so nice I'm thinking of
others right I'm gonna wish from now on
that I win the lottery and then I'll
know if it came true by the way we need
to be more specific with our wishes
right like whenever imploring on my
birthday candles I think that the movie
liar liar cuz that kids wish came true
when his dad can't lie right so you need
to make it specific that's the moral of
the story specific wishes you guys
specificity is key the Teen Choice
Awards for this weekend and we've got
the winners complete list
Riverdale was a big winner and that's
really all we care about they also won
because they flew private there and back
and I just I I don't care about the
awards I care about the logistics a
hundred percent plane was it I think CW
has a plane because I remember last year
to comic-con some of them were late and
they got on a plane with Melissa Benoist
okay who is Supergirl on CW so I'm like
it was definitely a CW plane
well CW like definitely has a plane
because I feel like all networks have to
but like at what level are you important
enough to the network to fly send plane
and now they got the whole cast like uh
madellaine Vanessa mail and they were
like live in little lifer i'li and I'm
just so happy for those kids you guys
thank you and you know what P some peeps
in the industry who I'm friends with
they're like when you're green in an
industry in you're on a new show that
gets very successful you and the cast
mates are tight as hell because you
don't you're not like divas yet but it
always gets to that place we're like
someone gets more successful or like
there's drama and I'm glad that the
Riverdale cast haven't gotten there yet
but like they're all shooting off so
much that like something's gonna happen
like it's too good to be true do you
know what I mean I agree but I think I
just hope that they're all smart enough
to know even if you don't like so and so
and so once those annoying bah-bah-bah
just know like this is it for
this is good as it's gonna get enjoy
every [ __ ] minute probably would they
don't they don't understand gratitude
you know no they really don't except
I've been seeing some funny like the
Riverdale fan accounts are hilarious and
I saw a video of Madeleine like every
time Cole talks in an interview where
she's like rolling her eyes I don't
think she likes Cole yeah no there's
definitely like underlying drama that
they're all pushing out of the rug
because they know that this is their big
break but they're gonna get to a point
where it's like they think they're too
good for the show that always happens
just know that you're not people hate
the thing that made them successful and
it's gonna shit's gonna go down and it's
crazy especially cuz they're all dating
hooking off for most people like Cole
Sprouse is like the breakout star and
Lily but like for me it's KJ and kami
like I'm obsessed with it was famous
before it I think I saw interviews
before they show but after the first
season they were like before we like
started filming we were so excited to
meet Cole's dad because of Suite Life of
Zack and Cody
he played Ross his son both I know and
friends which is like the most iconic
thing I think daddy like they really did
have these like blossoming careers and
they were so famous but they just
weren't like working actors it's your
phone on vibrate
it is and I'm sorry oh I'm just stealing
my book I felt it in my foot - yeah I'm
like I don't think that was my phone
though okay whatever continue um but now
it's like I think the world has decided
like because when you think of like who
went to the Met Gala like : Lilly wears
like if KJ and cami were dating I think
I would have preferred to see that I
agree personally but I think everyone
else her first I see : Lilly and you
know it I'll take whatever I think and I
don't not want to see that I mean if I
have like Vanessa Morgan dating
Brielle's Michael koib so weird how the
world is so small it's like are there
really five eligible male teens in the
world yes
that's crazy and Brielle Bearden's
dating all of them and it's a Dinah
Chris Lee that's crazy and I just I'm
loving the whole I just love everything
that Riverdale does so I saw a couple
pictures of like the cast going up to
take their surfboard home and it was
like all these kids and Mark Consuelos
and I was like shooting Marcus videos
ever feels like stupid do you know
anything
well actually you know that Mark
Consuelos his son was just cast to play
young Hyrum line and honestly him taking
this role and being away from his home
for like ten months out of the year is
worth it just because his kids career is
about to change his life hop off and go
smart I was never one for Kellie and
what's his name
mark mark Consuelos but
now I really am respectively in their
own fields the Riverdale evident oh I
love that Kelly like watches Riverdale
has the cast on knows what she's talking
about and you guys are killing it
honestly comments by celebs like makes
me hate Marc and Kelly but I kind of
like that because I read about them in
Andy's book and remember their
commercial they have like ten
commercials with the laundry machines
mm-hmm with all their kids like I just
thought it was so cute out like they
weren't afraid to sell out do you know
any me you can't be embarrassed of it
it's the Lisa Rinna syndrome and
honestly otherwise speaking to please
someone is syndrome so anymore gonna
have to become the face of depends I
know and they tried to tweet it depends
they don't want Twitter
well that's they're not in tune right no
but like their company for old people so
like no but because they don't have a
Twitter I don't know if they'll if
they'll be in tune enough to know about
Sonja Morgan yeah remember when Chris
did commercials for depends no does it
it's a rite of passage I'll do it you
said they Peter seventy seven figures
[ __ ] laughing you know what that
lines from I do I know what it's going
for at for at when he gets on the bus
with those college kids and they're like
like shut up here through your notes I'm
doing it I don't give a [ __ ] up to it
I'm nervous like wow you're psycho and
that one line that we like really common
too it wasn't any the important line it
was like okay psycho it's true okay here
are some of the winners choice action
movie Avengers infinity warm choice
action movie actor Robert Downey jr. I
thought this was the Teen Choice Award
yeah choice action movie actress
Scarlett Johansson Avengers infinity
Wars choice sci-fi movie black panther
Joyce sci-fi movie actor Chris Hemsworth
in Thor honestly I didn't know that
there were teens Choice Awards I thought
it was just Kids Choice Awards but like
good on Nickelodeon for being in tune
with what's necessary like Kids Choice
Awards like really they have sex like
kami Mendes in case you have had sex in
the shower after his dad was like almost
died so like that's not a kids show
that's a teen show yeah um choice drama
movie actors Zac Efron in the greatest
showman he beat Hugh Jackman which
honestly Hugh deserved it more but I'm
just glad but that run was there the
greatest showman is getting its shine
and a a14 choice drives the actress I
saw photos and you know what I was
thinking and I don't know if you'll
understand this reference cuz you don't
watch but Maddie Ziegler was there she
presented with Joey King and she's like
you know the breakout star her life has
changed from whatever
Chloe Lucas Yaak was there to who was
like always second to Maddie and like
when Maddie got to see it
like the whole show erupted and Chloe
and her mom left and I think they were
doing better without spoiler alert they
didn't she like has a book club on
YouTube it's really weird but I was
wondering like do they talk I feel like
the two of them must be fine like when
it's funny because when Nastya was here
she was telling us the saga of her
friendship with Shawn and how before the
Olympics of meeting and at the Olympics
they were best best friends and then
after the Olympics it was like Shana
Dancing with the Stars not she did this
and the way that people would talk about
them made them think that they weren't
friends and for six years they weren't
friends until one day eight years Marcus
is eight years she corrected well snitch
was here so I'm going to trust you on
your the fact checker for eight years
they weren't friends and then one day
like Shawn reach out to nasi lemak sent
her an email and they're now fiance's
and husbands were pushing for them to
get back together because they were like
that's not fit but nothing happened just
the media told them that they were at
but something's didn't happen with
Maddie and Chloe that's the difference
no but I feel like it was more so their
moms and like what happened yet then
like go fight so I feel like they must
be they're giving me an Aussie and Shawn
guides and I feel like they're gonna
come back together I'm just curious like
I know there's a lot of politics around
Dance Moms
and some of the girls are friends some
of them are still in the show Maddie is
like untouchable and like they all
secretly hate her but like still pretend
to be friends with her so they can have
as many Instagram followers as her but
it's like they also have a lot of
Instagram followers and everyone you
need to stop comparing yourself to other
people like Chloe you're doing great
you're at the Teen Choice Awards you're
on Tyler Henry medium well she yes was
the mom on there too yes mom is so
[ __ ] so like count your blessings
stop counting Maddie's because then
you'll always be disappointed but you're
doing good to girl you're on medium
you're on e I saw you
we interviewed Tyler Henry we did I was
wearing these pants when they split no
no sorry [ __ ] every time I wear these
pants they still put it down the middle
have you gotten that more the months you
keep fixing it I keep fixing them
because I want them to work when I
should just buy the expensive pair yeah
then I'll stop having to send them to
the cleaner that is so funny right so I
was sitting there Tyler Henry me 'i'm in
these pants and they were split down the
middle well you weren't sweating more
than him so don't worry that's true
uh-oh and Zack ins and I won for
greatest showman movie ship well he's in
love with her right he's in love with
all of his co-stars and I appreciate the
commitment to the craft man ya know I
like love to watch the movie I've now
watch it I've watched it two times in
the past week because it's officially on
all delta flights which is just I notice
ed that already but like it's so so
necessary to watch great showmen on a
plane
and by the way I know you say watching
on a plane it's like shitty the Delta
flight the Delta planes off [ __ ]
English the Delta TVs on their new
planes are huge like they're the size of
a covert iPad in that case you are
allowed to and they're clear like
they're not shitty and if you watch it
through the lens of like you know he's
really in love with her in real life Zac
Efron but Sunday yeah it's just so much
better it's just it's just so good you
guys
and then Riverdale one for like pretty
much every TV category and I'm so happy
for them
I'm so happy for Nickelodeon for being
into and you know who I'm really happy
for Margo snitch writer boss brighter
wrath writer writer writer Ross I didn't
write a Roscoe Paul was it afternoon
someone should tell him yeah we gotta
get that account back yes okay next
story is about the man of the year
Thomas Marko he should be he should be
TIME's Person of the Year because no one
is being talked about more by the way
that is such a good point and I feel
like time is actually really creative
with the people they put on the list and
I think you might be onto something when
is the list come out I feel like it just
I feel like he just came out to you but
hey there's like a million lists every
year he keeps riding this wave if they
do like the UM the geriatric time Person
of the Year
I'm voting Thomas Markel geriatric if
that's a kind word right it just means
old yeah
nicer than saying old I hung up on the
prints Thomas Marco reveals he put the
phone down on Harry in a heated call
following stage paparazzi photos and
admits he lied to the groom about his
role in the deal Shaddai better and wha
also known as thomas marco they have got
to get rid of him know or like can't you
like send him to like Siberia or
something we need we need them to hire
jay-z as an assassin because you know
jay-z hit like has people killed all the
time oh yeah we have to stop talking
like this because we're gonna get
ourselves cuz I was talking to Heather
on Friday and I brought up lines and
like even she got skittish and I was
like okay you're smart and we're stupid
okay okay just read the bonds on NT
about you saying okay Thomas Marco last
night were dragging he tried to kill huh
Breanna killed people don't know that
it's like important yeah he tried with a
bomb but thankfully it was really worse
left yeah
Thomas Marco laughs looks like the most
relatable thing of all time totally oh
man oh just let's make a [ __ ]
horrible joke and I together yeah
Thomas Marc
last night revealed how he dramatically
hung up on Prince Harry during a heated
telephone call after the mail on Sunday
exposed him for staging paparazzi photos
the Dutchess of Sussex father said he
was upset by Harry's tirade which came
as he recovered in hospital from a heart
attack although he admits and though he
admits he accepts how he was absolutely
right to admonish him he described the
timing of the phone call from the
princes rude honestly I'm surprised he
didn't record the phone call and sell it
totally and I was thinking how do they
know he's not recording it I guess in
order to get a phone call like someone
from the UK has to fly over and like
watch um the phone calls right and like
have it on a little phonogram right like
a telegram yeah the facts today in his
most explosive interview yet mr. Merkel
all coz also confesses that he lied to
the Prince when Harry asked him if he
had cooperated with a paparazzi
photographer to pose for shots one of
which showed him apparently being fitted
for a wedding suit mr. Marco told his
soon-to-be son-in-law that he was simply
being quote measured for a hoodie if
you're gonna lie at least be good at it
yeah like come up with something better
than that in our searingly frank and
revealing interview which mr. Marcos
vows will be his last haven't we heard
not the famous last words he adds that
one Megan told him there would be no
room for his speech at her wedding
leaving him feeling hurt to claims of
her rapprochement couple are wrong and
that they have not spoken for months and
three he doesn't care about the Royals
and wants his old life back then stop
talking to the press him and Samantha
are so out of control I can't with these
stories and look I don't even want to
talk about it because it's working like
he what he wants to get done is working
and like in his favor she's on Celebrity
Big Brother at the half sister like
force all good on CBS Irving so in tune
with what's necessary but like stop
making stupid people famous and like
every time he opens his mouth I
literally want to choke him shut the
[ __ ] up no like seriously and apparently
the call ended and I don't know if it's
in this article I saw it on e it was
like maybe I'll just die so you two can
pretend to be sad are you for real - I
know I just like Meg has so much on her
plate except nothing at all because
she's so skinny
and because she can't eat because her
father is ruining her life eh kitty cuz
like if she does before the Queen like
they'll banish her okay somebody rose I
heard she's having a hard time with it's
like she has so much on her plate yet
she can't even eat imagine the feelings
I actually can't even imagine that I
can't imagine being in the presence of
food and not eating it right I can
imagine
nothing on my plate not eating or having
everything on my plate and eat it yeah
having so much on your plate and not
even eating her legs are so small her
ankles yeah Thomas Markel is so
treacherous like every time he speaks I
get the biggest Pitt no of course every
time I see his name in the headlines
like it's like massive I roll right and
it's just like I'm getting to the place
that I got you with I Chloe interest in
like I'm almost over talking about I'm
about to talk about him that much but
this just seems like so crazy that he's
copping to it all he he hung up on
Prince Harry like who do you think you
are and it's like he I don't know if he
gets this or not but like the reason why
they don't want to talk to youse cuz
every time they do they say something to
the press so they finally gave you an
opportunity to talk to them and what do
you do you do an exclusive interview
with the Daily Mail like are you not
understanding or you're just being
stupid you know right
maybe both right okay fifth and final
story is it like a story that really
took the world by storm but a man stole
a plane from horizon air and crashed it
so here's the latest on the horizon q400
story that made an unauthorized
unauthorized takeoff from seattle-tacoma
International Airport on Friday night
and crashed into South Puget Sound's
what kind of plane we talked in like a
two-seater or like a 747 I think we're
talking like a 747 so the man who took a
rise in air he'd be really smart to
super go prop plane that doesn't sound
like a 737 that sounds like Wright
brothers with the propeller totally from
ctek international airport and crashed
it on Ketron Island Friday night was
Richard Russell a 29 year old ground
service agent well-liked by co-workers
Russell took off from Sea Tac at around
8 p.m. and flew above Puget Sound for
about 75 minutes that's a long time
doing aerial stunts and being trailed by
two f-15c fighter jets before crashing
he is presumed dead the 30s a three
point five year old employee three and a
half year old employee the Seattle Times
man you guys are confusing as [ __ ] the
three point five year employee of
horizon that's weird that's weird just
be like the almost four years
right the three-and-a-half year employee
yeah it's 2:35 know what the employee
the the longtime employee of Verizon
Russell was moved was born in Key West
Florida and moved to Alaska at age 7 he
lived in Coos Bay Oregon before moving
to Sumner Pierce Colorado and
for 2015 he did not have a pilot's
license so this man stole a plane that
did some tracks crash sorry if you don't
have a pilot's license like if if I was
in a plane ready to feel it I wouldn't
even know how to like move it not even
not even fly it but like drive on the
tarmac it's so so many buttons here's
the thing when I first heard this story
I hadn't clicked in read I was just
seeing headlines and I was confused like
he stole the plane who was on it he
crashed she died what happened anyone
else get hurt and now I'm reading this
story and I'm spent I'm more confused
and I blame the Seattle Times and people
I will never be sourcing you again
people are like it's such a sad story
but like is it first of all you could
have danger endangered so many people
like what if he guys like crashed into a
school right now whole you just believe
that no one was injured on Ketron island
because it's a sparsely populated island
however like it could have been more
populated he didn't know where the [ __ ]
he was going according to the comments
it was a q400 commercial flight that can
carry that can carry up to 700 people 70
70 70 70 person plane like crashing into
a park but like kids like I'm sorry it
is sad cuz someone died but like he's a
criminal and like how stupid are you to
start less yeah you don't have a [ __ ]
license and then when you're in the air
you have to be do you ever see breaking
dad yeah when that guy from aircraft at
traffic control his daughter just
overdosed on heroin and he's so upset
that he accidentally crashed his two
planes into each other in the sky like
you have to be directed I get you won't
be watching right now but I had no
anything you have to do you have to
direct be directed which way to go
because you don't know where the other
planes are you can't really see them in
the clouds so you're up there like an
[ __ ] not knowing where other planes
are you could have heard so many people
so yes while I'm very sad that someone
had to die like I'm glad he didn't go he
could still be over there it could be
worse how much fuel to the AB that we
could reporting be report you mentioned
all the people he definitely displaced
on the tarmac I would have been so
[ __ ] pissed there were planes coming
and going and nobody can do anything cuz
this [ __ ] is doing slips in the sky
sorry I don't feel bad I don't feel bad
II I mean I still don't know the whole
story
because I couldn't understand it but it
doesn't it could have been way worse and
this is reckless reckless endangerment
any masturbatory emissions could be
termed reckless abandonment
masturbatory do you know if that's fun
no we bond masturbatory yeah when she's
talking about the eggs why now why this
sperm yeah yeah sorry how could I forget
anyways those are the fast hi stories
that you needed to know
morning and now we're gonna talk about
last night's episode of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians because it's like the
most interesting thing on TV right I
haven't kept up with the Kardashians and
Yola usually but character marathon once
every couple months and I catch up I
catch the premiere because they always
hype it up I'm like who's pregnant
who's yeah in the hospital but now I'm
like in it to win it and they've really
perfected their formula because the show
is 50% commercials and then the resting
50% is like 15% drama 15% prank [ __ ]
secondary storyline and the and then the
20% left is like b-roll of them walking
places with like the film moving in the
palm trees of Calabasas and the cars
right and I have to be honest this was a
great episode because the 15 percent of
drama 15 percent drama was there it was
premium and we any sort of close the
book on QWERTY not an hour but now we're
walking on eggshells so that it's like
it's gonna erupt can't wait then the 15%
a prank was [ __ ] hilarious
I was crying except it's like they had
this idea for the prank and they needed
to transition into it and Chloe was like
trying to make art shaming a thing like
so hard no but I didn't think she did
cuz she literally says to Scott in like
passing she was like Krista Chyna RJ
mean it's like what the [ __ ] goes art
shame like he was the one who picked up
on it and then they made it a thing and
I just say that herpes is really kind of
good no they were when they were framed
that red one yeah with like the pants
true I hope that Chris finds out that
it's fake by watching last night's
episode
and honestly Chloe should become an
artist under the pen-name
art Vandelay by the Jeep I know it was a
running joke from Seinfeld like oh yeah
every time I make something up they
would use vandalize so he was he was
getting on George his hands I was
getting unemployment and he didn't wanna
stop getting the checks but the lady was
like you need to prove that you've been
like trying to get a job and we can send
you the check and he claims that he had
a really promising interview at Vandal a
latex industries and it's just like
every time they do something fake it's
like in friends burn like they all came
up with fake names it's like I always
say Regina phalange like I can Adam it's
like it's Ben's life and it was just
like Vanna supreme and like nobody
watching the Kardashians knows that
reference no but that's why that's even
greater and I really think that Khloe
should start in our career because
people would buy her her pieces totally
and like art family could like take over
the world know and they could like
auction off for a lot of money those two
specifically like I thought they were so
pretty the names of the pieces - who
were they there was that one was like
the
the faces of lack the faces of life oh
my god wait and you know how you know it
was really real because when they were
done talking him and Scott was like you
were so rude with your sunglasses Chris
felt so bad they give Chris the biggest
like the fact that Corey was like damn
this is funny Christmas really be like a
hopper on two things that are cool yeah
and exposing her it's like so mean it's
so embarrassing it's [ __ ] hilarious
and then when Kim was on the phone with
Chris and she was crying I think she put
her phone him you choose like I want to
get Connie I get for the new honey be
like a piece of art I've heard about
this new night art Vandelay Chris was
like well have you heard about this new
guy art Vandelay and Kim was like you
know him like I was actually laughing
out loud and I judge any TV show by how
many times I'm able to laugh yeah
usually at zero but last night as day
was laughing too like it was so fun so
when the prank is good it's good but
like when critic rains when kick Chris
is having empty nest syndrome even
though she has two eight-year-olds at
home and she gets a monkey not here for
it Todd kraines
premium that's still the number one
prank of all time but our van delay is
number two and they've really elevated
Todd kraines his real estate career like
he's a he's a big name he's a big-time
real estate big time magazine yesterday
showing your apartment he wouldn't [ __ ]
you like that otally
now let's talk about the 15% drama
because it was premium as how Courtney
still a whiney face [ __ ] and now she's
starting to contradict herself because
last week she all she was saying was
like I'm a mom and I want to kind of
understand about she's like you know
what I don't want these aren't my
priorities my parties are my kids like
I'm gonna be a [ __ ] and make my
priorities number one because mine are
more valuable than yours fine like she
was taking a moral high ground but this
week it's like you guys are something to
me because I travel all the time but why
you keep traveling if all you wanna do
is because we're kids you can't spend
you can't spend a couple hours late
missing then giving them dinner but you
could take a week off every six weeks
right because your boyfriend is living
the country so now we know you're
traveling to see your boyfriend this
isn't about your kids anymore
yeah and I'm just like so here for the
calling out of Kourtney's therapist who
is clearly brainwashing her she's always
been so weird with her therapist and
this one it seems like she's a new therm
yeah
plus she always had that girl Erica
remembers founded with the boyfriend is
a recipe for disaster for them but
success for a show I think Eunice was
like poor and and the girl had way I
can't think of Eunice now somewhat out
she's the man with someone I'm the toast
who's pointing that out that Eunice from
she's the man is also
enos spelled differently eun I see us
knowing back to Kourtney's therapist
yeah yeah hold on I'm I was oh do you
think that Eunice is one poisoning her
I don't think Eunice is helping any you
know what really makes a lot of sense to
me now because I think the therapist is
telling Kourtney that her family are
discussing human beings and then I think
Eunice is like retweet and we go you can
see that with the common when Eunice
commented on her picture where she's
showing your booty he was like why did
you do stew things like this to get
attention like that's that sort of
thinking that Kourtney's in right now
right but it's the same thing so
Kourtney's like those aren't on my
priority so why you putting a big
picture of your ass on Instagram because
she needs those followers right why was
she putting a picture of her in a thong
like you don't want to be that but like
your sister is yet here you are out here
thirsting still we won't probably that
scene where they're sitting which I
think was the movie theater that little
room was so cute with the candy oh my
god none of them ate one thing I was all
I could think about I know as I please
just eat one when she's sitting there
like with that smirk on her face like
editing her photos like I've never
wanted to cut a [ __ ] more like it was
so Carol like so smug like with that
little smile and get that [ __ ]
kimochi phone case right irony is it
lost like she is so upset about all this
meanwhile she's literally holding a
phone case that just represents like her
entire argument like it's just you don't
want to bear the fruits of your family's
labor yet you do but you complain about
it all the time and you say that you
have different values in them and you
like judge them for doing things that
make you money but you're using a phone
case that is a part of the company and I
saw a tweet that was from last week I
was like Kourtney's like yelling at Kim
yet she's still using her phone case
like that's the level of support these
sisters have each other no no no no
you're reading it all wrong that's not
her supporting that's just ironic and
not being intuitive about stuff isn't it
ironic don't you think it's like on your
wedding cake it's free
when you've already paid it's goodbye
is that yeah I just add and take now I'm
seeing a problem with that song because
none of the example she mentions are
ironic it's just bad timing
it's like it's a traffic jam when you're
already late no that's not you were late
that's your wedding day it's just some
that ironic stuff
oh wait it's like 10,000 spoons when all
you need is a knife no also just like
sucks it's not ironic just grab a spoon
it's like meeting the man of your dreams
and then meeting his beautiful wine
would you say if they didn't students
and all you need it's a knife let's just
say grab a spoon totally like not even
ironic but meeting the man of your
dreams and meaning his beautiful wife
these are all bad luck none of these
scenarios are ironic and that's always
bothered me about the song cuz it's an
amazing song but it's factually
incorrect I I guess I guess it's just
the wrong like title of the song but
they're all but you know they say
there's no definition for the word
ironic yes like what is ironic do you
mean it's just when something is ironic
right like no it's it's
it's Kim's face on your face as you're
arguing about like not being wanting to
like shoot the show anymore exactly and
by the way the Accrediting breaking down
of the four oh my god think the breaking
down of the fourth wall is everything
that I need when James Corden looks at
the camera in a sec are we keeping up
right now first of all him being on the
show so for me I'm when they said this
is biggie I'm like that's so mean he's
just like a little overweight understand
and realize trolls called biggie which
is like a popular movie for kids and
like I love that Kim knows that it's
like proof that she's like a good mom
and like actually spends time with her
kids and then when Kim and Chloe look at
the camera they're like to the therapist
you mean watching us we hate you like I
love the address and then when Kim's in
the side bar any of you and it she goes
Courtney if you can't commit to filming
a full season of a show like that we're
talking on right now like yeah that's
irony like the addressing of the forth
of the camera breaking down of the
fourth wall is what I live for
in reality shows and nobody does it
enough because they think it's like
breaking the formula but I've just been
waiting for a reality show to address
the fact that there are cameras around
like when Courtney when Chloe was in
Kim's office when Chloe was in Chris's
office you need County man and they
didn't try and hide him it was great
also then there was like this sub sub
sub sub sub plot of Kendall moving in
with Kim and then Kim not telling
and Kendall in her interview she's like
I'm gonna get it out of her no matter
what it takes like and I'm like with a
[ __ ] shoe I like to 12 other sisters
like no other sisters you have a billion
dollar stay in the hotel other sisters
to say that you have your mom's house
that has rooms of plenty you can go say
Dotel like I'm not worried about you and
Emily that him you have a team of 10
people to move everything for you find a
place for you pay for it like you don't
have to lift a finger you just someone
else I tell you where to go and they're
gonna arrange a car for you to get there
right like I'm not worried about you and
neither and neither is Kim and she was
just being so annoying she's like I'm
gonna get her to confront finally shop
to confront her confrontation fears I
this is it this is the big one that was
really stupid that was really fabulous
and I just want to know how much each of
them make from the show like Kylie
obviously doesn't take a dollar from the
show and they're okay with her not being
on it because she's not putting any
money forward and old takes a little
money because she shows up like once an
episode yeah then I think Kourtney look
I think Chris Pratt gets 10% of everyone
well it was 100 million dollar deal so I
think Chris gets 10 million I don't know
I just where she got coming up some more
Kim or Chloe Oh Kim because it's like it
was now Kim the shows they tried it with
how Kim for a while and it was not fine
but I think it goes Kim khloé him I
don't know where Chris is she's over
here somewhere
Kim Khloe Kourtney Kendall and what
they're not saying is like you committed
to a full show okay you're getting paid
for a full show and you're like Kylie's
not on it but Carly's not taking money
if you want to be on it you're gonna
take the money we'll split it but she
said she can't live without that money
right so they're not saying that part
it's like you can't commit to filming a
full season okay but you're taking the
money for it but they're not going to
say that no not at all anyways
congratulations to the whole Kardashian
team on on a great season so far
yeah I'm enjoying it it's a daytime TV
lunch I'm like looking forward to it all
the time I'm having anxiety about moving
because my DVR is finally in a good
place where I'm not missing [ __ ] and
then to have to get like a new cable
provider and then like rerecord all my
[ __ ] like I know I'm gonna miss stuff
and I have on there um my CNBC I haven't
recorded squawk
yes walk Ally and I have my something
else like two important things that like
I'm gonna have to get rid of well you
can download them on Hulu which I now
have a login for so I've been watching
real oh and it's so crazy it's a really
good show I know I'm just I'm so over
the bachelor like I can't even I'm so
over the bachelor and it's like I feel
like it's very similar to that while
there's a fly in here are we hungry Oh
buddy Scott is definitely taking a
cutting ninety-two oh yeah because he's
working hard aren't Vandelay and those
funny that was so funny I want to buy a
piece I feel it Chloe if you're watching
like you should pursue this 1,000%
you'll be at Art Basel next year and
Chris will be clamoring for your work
totally or to take 10% of it right
anyways that's our show today thank you
all for tuning in camp toe sticks are
available at the link and our Instagram
bio you guys it's gonna be fun and it's
gotten a couple questions here's the
thing people like can I leave X a mic
[ __ ] we're not your counselors you can
leave whenever you want come and go as
you please like you want to get their
day late great you want to leave a day
early I don't give a [ __ ] it's gonna be
a grand ol time confirmed in the
Facebook group that there are girls who
know how to braid hair so like we're all
set because we're in a good place if you
are coming from New York or the New York
area or you want to fly into New York
there will be a bus out of New York City
just we need to know how many people are
gonna be on it and then we will give you
the details so do not worry about that
what else did we need to announce about
cam 2 it's just gonna be like funnest
[ __ ] I'm so ok merch is not gonna become
available for other people it's only for
people who experienced it and right I
think we'll probably give it to you for
free but we have a decided that yet
because we're working super hard on our
merch site which is not free but it's
affordable hotel and premium and premium
and like we could have really sit months
ago and it would have been a pile of
[ __ ] but yeah we're working hard I'm
like honestly I would say we're we're
less than a month out yeah but we're not
gonna we're not gonna count our chickens
before they have yeah
I need your shout out to toaster like I
love supporting toaster owned businesses
toaster workers like people have been
commenting on our Instagram stories
lately because they've been premium
content knocked out with our games and
our trivia and we hired a toaster Taylor
oh and she's a she's an OG brought there
like she was making amazing content on
her morning toast lingo like Vanna cow
and we were like [ __ ] you make this for
us amazing
Zoe score doll runt works like for a
major merge company on the west coast
and she reached out to me and she's been
helping us so much like literally I was
emailing her till 4:00 in the morning on
Saturday and she was like a wake and
just answering me like in 10 seconds
I just love supporting toaster
entrepreneurship no save where to host
our own that we're supporting to a
certain businesses yes small businesses
and if you are on the
Eventbrite page for camp toast the
password is all caps premium right you
guys it's gonna be so fun like oh if you
do we show up and everything will be
there for you
friends a good time alcohol food
activities these jackets just harnesses
for the ropes course OC style it's gonna
be just so [ __ ] fun but there are any
toast our own video ography companies
reach out because I want to make like a
bomb-ass promotional video for like all
of our good times I can and like we're
gonna need your hand stuff a technic
like the grounds are also a weight loss
cam so like we can also make it like
alright alright the right area if you
want to some weight like this is you're
gonna lose weight it will split up the
camp because it was originated with
Jackie and people who want to hang out
on the ropes course we're gonna have
snitch teaching fitness classes like
there's that's Jackie you're not selling
it at all no no there's gonna be snacks
everywhere like it's wine and beer it's
like what's it called what's that thing
called that retreat place can remesh
toast right no [ __ ] way I don't want
to go it's gonna be sick okay you could
you could either sign up for camp toast
with Jackie where like you do aerobics
in the morning or camp tossing me where
you sleep till noon and get beer for
lunch I'm waking up early I want I
wanted to Emily I want to hit every
single activity I want to do the ropes
course three times camp choice is what
you make it you want to sleep all day
cool me too
you don't sure whatever zip line thank
you all so much for watching the
millennium morning show the morning
totes we go live on YouTube and Facebook
even though we're thinking about
transitioning to only YouTube because
Facebook sucks these days I'm just like
over it let us know your thoughts on
that
totally I've been watching on Facebook
and I've been frozen forever I don't
know if it's me or if it's Facebook no I
watched with Ben on YouTube and I was
having the most premium experience like
the comments were just great like I was
loving it okay it's gonna happen soon
yeah we're making the transition but
thanks for watching make sure you
subscribe to us on youtube at morning
toast make sure like us on facebook at
the morning toast but if you're a
commuter you can't make it in time you
live on the west coast gotta meet Sally
at the water cooler feel free to
subscribe to us on the podcast app just
search the morning toast and if you're
an Android user you've been able to
listen to us on soundcloud but we have
just been approved to be uploaded to
spotify so hopefully that will happen
this week they are very slow with their
emails but I am following up don't you
worry which I just feel like it's gonna
be so exciting for like discoverability
I feel like we're gonna get a lot of new
toasters well I mean I just I'm obsessed
with Spotify as a human being know that
I can now listen to myself on Spotify
that's like a dream come true for me
I've been getting I think we've been
getting like so many new toasters
recently because I keep getting tweeted
out like just not about the money chose
which hey I don't know how you just
found out
for you and be like welcome and Slevin
join our Facebook group yet at the
morning toast it's for toasters just
meet Network there's 7 million subgroups
that you could join about like I don't
know give a chronic illness are you
pregnant or planning wedding are you a
book nerd like everything you want are
you planning a wedding
torture torch thank you so make sure you
subscribe to the patreon page for our
premium video behind-the-scenes coming
out later today it's gonna if you're a
country music fan it's like a behind the
scenes look at the concert and it's just
gonna be so much [ __ ] fun tell a
friend about the toast we love ya
yeah that's your that's your work for
today yeah homework we'll find a friend
and convert them so we can double our
audience and we're talking about the
founder tomorrow for the toast movie of
the week
you